the United Kingdom is collapsing right  now nearly a decade ago it was described  as one of the best places to live but  that's no longer the case now there's  anger and civil unrest in the streets  there have been strikes literally every  day since the middle of December for  every major industry in the country  nurses postal workers firefighters  public transportation you name it any  occupation critical to keeping Society  Running has been shutting down living  standards are now lower than they were  in the 1950s due to higher cost of  living and low wages the divorce rate is  skyrocketing to a whole new record  they've had three prime ministers in the  last 12 months which shows us that